[Music]
laugh and the world laughs with you fake
laugh and the world could tell in the
first cross-cultural experiment of its
kind researchers asked 884 people from
21 different cultures in six regions
around the world to listen to recordings
of real spontaneous lacquers and fake
volitional laughter recorded from u.s.
college - women can you tell the
difference
here's fake here's real real fake okay
now you can try guessing again the first
one option one was the real laughter so
in this study on average nearly
two-thirds of listeners in each culture
could tell the difference between real
and fake laughs genuine chuckles were
typically higher pitched and louder
similar characteristics are seen in
cries of pain and anguish suggesting
that real laughter is a more emotional
and primal response that emerged early
in human evolution the experiments show
that despite cultural differences people
perceive laughter in generally the same
way suggesting giggles and guffaws
constitute a basic and universal part of
human behavior
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]